yes the jury here at mold Crown Court
just in the last five minutes or so
coming to that verdict in the end their
deliberations uh taking under five hours
they went out at around two o'clock
yesterday afternoon after hearing what
has to be said very difficult evidence
detailing the the conditions that Kaylee
tip had that 16 year old disabled
teenager was living in she was found
dead in her home on the 10th of October
2020 paramedics who attended her
attended the initial 999 call out found
her unresponsive in bed in a room that
was filled with junk food cartons
incontinence pads that were soiled in a
room that was full of rubbish and
described by one police officer as quite
revolting he described the stench in the
room that Kaylee was living in as being
something that made him Rich he
describing it quite simply as something
that he had never smelt for now Kaylee's
mother Sarah Lloyd Jones excuse me
there's just a we are assembling here
just for a police press conference if
you're seeing someone in front of our
frame there
um Sarah Lloyd Jones Cody tip for his
mother had earlier pleaded guilty to
that charge of gross negligent
manslaughter but that is something which
Alan tetford her father who's 45
denied the jury here though finding that
he was as equally responsible for the
conditions that his daughter were living
in which led to her death which a
pathologist said was due to infections
caused by ulcers on her legs that had
been left untreated her parents saying
that they hadn't taken their daughter to
see a doctor because of the covert
lockdowns that were in place at that
time teachers describing this teenager
who has spina bifida who was in a
wheelchair but they described her as
someone who was Lively fiercely
independent someone who'd even been
considered to join the paralympic
basketball team at one point but by the
time of her death weighed more than 22
stone was in a terrible physical
condition forensic forensics team saying
that it felt like they hadn't she hadn't
been washed properly for several weeks
and today her father Alan tipford being
found guilty of her man's daughter by
gross neglect we understand sentencing
is due for both Alan tipford and
Kaylee's mother Sarah Lloyd Jones will
take place in Swansea on March 1st